from the moment I heard my next guest
music I was a fan my mom actually showed
me her record and I loved her I even
performed her song you say for our first
show in quarantine her music is very
necessary for these times any time but
it's especially important right now so
let's bring her in here hi hey Kelly Hey
I know the last time we ran into each
other I was worried but we were at
dinner but I kept fan of yours and I
hope that shows the Greek really mean
well but if you had to postpone your
tour right so when do you plan on
kicking that back off 20 21 yes so we
start back again in 20 21 and I am so
ready I'm telling you I miss it's like
everybody's in the road becomes your
family you know they're like your people
and so just being apart and being away
I'm like how much longer I feel like
every day feels like it's 30 hours not
24 hours you know it's like every day
that goes by gosh I just I missed the
people I miss the environment on this
the energy of being able to just sing
and have people experience something
collectively together I just I miss the
environment and I miss my friends you
know I get it so tell me about the song
you're gonna perform it's called rescue
rescue is probably one of the most
personal songs on the record I remember
writing it in mind of a loved one and
the thing about it is I don't know if
this has ever happened to you where you
write a song but it's almost like the
song write to you before you write it I
don't know if that makes sense but it's
like you especially four times right now
like especially with what's going on
it's like that song couldn't have been
more real and more potent for such a
time as this but it's like you're
experiencing it with every other person
who's listening but yeah I don't know if
that makes sense where it's like you
write the song but the song really rides
to you before you write it like it's an
experience that
is yet to be had like you're about to
have that experience but you don't even
realize it and you're just riding and
you're I think and you're enjoying it
and then all of a sudden it's like whoa
this became real you know I agree I
agree subscribe to my channel subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going